>> Hi, welcome to Introduction to Hadoop
and MapReduce. I'm Sarah Sproehnle. I'm the Vice
President of Educational Services at Cloudera, the company
that helps develop, support, and manage Apache Hadoop.
>> And I'm Ian Wrigley. I'm Cloudera's Senior Curriculum Manager. Between us,
Sarah and I have been responsible for bringing Hadoop training to well
over 20,000 people, and we're excited to bring it to a much
larger audience with Udacity. So during
this course, we're going to talk about what
big data is, what Hadoop is, why Hadoop's useful,
and we're going to teach you how to write MapReduce code.
>> In fact, by the end of the course, you'll write a MapReduce
program that efficiently processes a very large web server log. And by the
end of Lesson Two, you'll already be running a MapReduce job in Apache
Hadoop. So please join us to learn more about Apache Hadoop and MapReduce.